remember that lunatic Republican Kansas
secretary of state Kris Kobach who is
helping Donald Trump quote investigate
the widespread voter fraud from the 2016
election voter fraud that quite
obviously never existed and doesn't
exist Donald Trump claiming that three
to five million people voted illegally
for Hillary Clinton
totally fantasy world claim like most of
the claims that Trump is made so far the
whole point of this initiative to look
into strengthening voter blah blah blah
it appears to be a pretext for creating
even more aggressive voter ID laws but
let's put that aside for a second the
guy who is the vice chairman of the
initiative is Kris Kobach he's the
Kansas secretary of state running for
governor is that you mentioned up campus
in 2018 he asked all 50 states for their
full voter roll data and a reminder
about Kris Kobach he's the guy who
complained publicly many times about
undocumented immigrants voting in Kansas
even though there are only five alleged
cases in Kansas in the last 13 years
he's the guy who didn't even know how to
walk around with classified or secret
documents sensitive document about the
plan for fighting terror with Donald
Trump he walked around with like a
completely open manila envelope where
you could just take a picture and read
what the plan was I mean just an
embarrassingly incompetent guy he asked
for all of this data so what is in this
voter data voter names birthdays the
last four digits of their social
security numbers as well as their voting
history dating back to 2006 now that
doesn't mean who they voted for it means
whether you voted but regardless
starting with the Massachusetts
Secretary of State many states now 44
states have said sorry Danny Boy and
Chris were not sharing it states were
given a deadline of July 14th to submit
this information 44 states so far led by
our home state of Massachusetts have
said nah no thanks some said we can't
provide the social security numbers even
the last four others said we're not
going to do it in the way you requested
which is through an online portal and
what is amazing is that you've got
Kentucky and California
agreeing about something here which is
we're not giving you the information you
know that the request is outrageous when
Kentucky and California are on the same
page it makes you think what six states
are volunteering the event version I
think some of it just to be clear some
of those have not yet refused they
haven't necessarily agreed yet
well I think refusing makes total sense
we just learned about two weeks ago that
there's a Republican analytics firm who
who stored sensitive voter data onto
some unsecured servers they of course
that information got leaked I don't know
if there was social security numbers on
there but certainly dates of birth and
phone numbers and addresses and that was
of sixty-one percent of the American
public why would we trust one of trumps
hacks then in that case to have that
information so that's question one which
Pat is pointing out which is does anyone
trust the Trump administration with this
information you'd have to be a [ __ ] to
say yes but then there's question number
two which is why do they need this
information how will we fix the problem
a problem that of course doesn't exist
with this information instead what's
more likely is that this is the type of
information that will be used to further
suppress the vote by figuring out hey
where are more Democrats voting where
are more Republicans voting what types
of elections are they voting in where do
they live this is all the real goal of
what's going on here now I'm sure
Republicans will be on our side on this
Pat right because this is the assertion
of states rights a constitutionally
protected form of expression by States
the ability to assert their state's
right I'm sure Republicans will say good
for the states asserting their rights no
that's not what they're saying where are
you on this is my question to the
right-wingers anyone even hints at a
list of the guns in the United States
and right-wingers lose their heads Trump
now wants a list of all voters and
whether they voted and they're silent
how do they justify that this is
something that you have a constitutional
right to right to vote it's not a
privilege and you can't deny that for
any reason based on you know race or
gender or anything else or finances
finances as often comes up with voter
IDs if you look back in history at who
has gathered
compiled voting data I'm not talking
about in the u.s. I don't even have to
mention anybody - you just look back
over the last couple of hundred years
around the world at who has sought to
gather and compile voting data it's not
great company that Donald Trump and Kris
Kobach are putting themselves in discuss
this with us on our reddit discussion
forum david pakman.com slash re d di t
not good folks not good believe me on
this today's program is made possible in
part by Gamefly which is sort of like
netflix for video games they've got over
8,000 new and classic games for xbox one
Xbox 360 ps4 ps3 Wii and a bunch of
other platforms and you can also stream
games you don't even need a gaming
console or a computer because you can
stream games through your Amazon fire
stick or Roku box and then use your
mobile phone as the controller you can
play as many games as you want for one
monthly fee and if you find some games
you want to keep you can buy them for a
low used price never with due dates or
late fees and our audience can get a
30-day free trial at Gamefly offer.com
slash TDP s the games are shipped
directly to you with return envelopes
included no contracts and you can also
stream the games I think I mentioned
that you can also rent games through the
mobile app get a free 30-day trial for
David Pakman show viewers and listeners
and support our show at Gamefly
offer.com forward slash TDP s